Hmm testing one to all right. Sorry for
the delay. We've had a few technical difficulties this evening.
I want you to see I'm going to be looking at some fantastic Graphics
that you will not be able to see.
But we're gonna talk first
about the pathway. We're not satisfied for
someone just to come to one section of the pie. Yes,
we want to worship together and we'll sing God's
word together and hear God's word preach pray together, but
we want to move that person from an experience where
they set silently into a relational environment
with their community group. Now every community
group is an open Group, which means you can come On Any Sunday and
feel welcome right away, but we're
not satisfied with a group large enough
to wear some people cannot speak from week to week
and no one knows that they haven't spoken. We would
love to get them into a an intentional relational
environment with a reproducible process so that
a leader can pour into them so that they they
go from largely silent with one person
having studied to now
the group together is thinking
about the same passage And discussing it as
And so that's the micro group now outside of that
micro group. We've not talked about this much.
But there is an opportunity to go one-on-one. Now,
the one-on-one is on a ask needed basis. You
don't need to meet weekly one-on-one. But
occasionally this has happened in the groups in the
small groups micro groups that I've discipled is that
somebody will say something in the course of a discussion
that you know needs to be followed up on but shouldn't
necessarily be followed up on in the
group.
Rusty I shared with you Rusty story
rusty said one time that he was really frustrated
in his marriage because when he got home she didn't seem
to be interested in him and he didn't think
that was right and he was going to just get busy playing golfers. I
don't know what he said but it wasn't in it wasn't the right answer
and I could have said Rusty that's not the
right answer, you know better than that, but that's that's not the kind
of relationship. We're going for in this option group on the
way to the car.
In the parking lot one-on-one. I said Rusty.
We need to get together this week. He goes. I know it.
You know.
any
we're gonna private conversation and he knew that at that
moment. I was going to encourage him and I was going to give him a little
homework assignment. It was going to be just he and I and sure
enough it. They were just fine.
He had just gotten into a rut and he needed
somebody to come alongside him and courage him. So that's the pathway. The
pathway is from a disconnected.
members of the church
to relationally connected and then intimately
connected in A discipleship experience
where they're they're concerned
about one another and so
that's that's one thing we talked about what else that we
talked about. What is the disciples anybody know the definition of
disciple?
If I started you off.
One who is following?
Oh see I I made it intentionally easy.
Not all the answers are going to end with Jesus. Okay. So
yes one who is following
Jesus one? Who is do what?
Changed by Jesus so
Let me just share with you. This is the hard part about discipleship. Okay
care groups or Community groups.
We can kind of track your metrics through
attendance. We know whether you're
attendance is holding steady growing or
falling. Okay, but in discipleship, we're
asking in a micro group. We're asking that
you cap your attendance at four.
You say well if somebody's comes we're down 25% or
doesn't come we're down 25% Yeah, that's not
we don't care about that. Right? What we care
about is transformed lives and it's really difficult to
attract the metrics of
a life that is changing. You know it
in your own heart when it's happening, you know,
when you've stepped away from the
the indwelling of the Holy Spirit. I'm
in the spirit is always with you, but you can grieve the
Holy Spirit and this is a great story. You
can tell I'm not using notes how many of you have grieve the Holy Spirit at least
one time in your life. Okay today? Yeah. Okay hands up
and right you can grieve the Holy Spirit, but you
can also walk with the Holy Spirit be
filled with the Holy Spirit indwelt and empowered by
the Holy Spirit and that's what we're seeking to do in a
micro group is that we know in fact I can
take you back to my very first group and I
can look on the face of each one of those teenage.
Boys, and I can tell you who's walking with
the spirit or not just by the countenance on their face.
That's the truth. And I think you'll be able to experience
the exact same thing once you
Once you get involved in the micro group like that, so one who's following Jesus
one who's being changed by Jesus and one is committed to the mission of
Jesus and that's disciple making so let's
talk about tonight. Let's turn to page four.
Page four in your curriculum talks about casting the vision.
Now, we know that the vision statement
of our church is to love equip one
another to love Jesus and to live sense and
this pathway is taking us outside of
the building.
into a relational environment of your choosing
We're not going to tell you where to meet or when
to meet. I would encourage weekly some say
you can do it bi-weekly, but I would encourage weekly but
but we would like for you to do it off campus and then
one another's homes in the right coffee shop
or restaurant some coffee shops are very busy. And
so that's not a great relational environment some you know,
when how many of you guys remember when concrete polished
concrete got real popular.
Yeah, it's a horrible place to listen if everything
is hard like that, right? So anyway, so
you're looking to take your your mission
the disciple making mission on the
road you're living scent you're off campus, but
what's what's the
actual mission statement that we
want to become a hub before an
all ages disciple making movement. So we're actually
we talk about the casting the vision. This
is not the church's Vision. This is another Sunday
school answer look down over here because you guys got Jesus
so quickly while ago
Who is the church?
We are okay. Let me all said people and
because you were thinking about here's the church. Here's the
steeple open the doors and see.
All the people well now we are the church. I am
the church. This is not the church's Vision.
This is my vision. So that's what it means to cast
vision. And the first thing we have to do when
we're casting vision is resist the
temptation to repeat old patterns.
Let me just warn you that this is
a serious concern for me. Okay, because
I'm getting older and the older I get the harder
it is for me to change my my rhythm my patterns
last week Carol and
I went to California to be with granddaughters and
my daughter and her husband. We had a
great trip, but about three days in both. She and I were thinking.
Who?
I can't wait to get home, you know, but why
because we know where we're going to sleep when we're gonna go to bed when we're
going to get up how we're going to get up what's gonna happen when we get up that doesn't
happen at this new house with all these little
Tyrant granddaughters
They tell me when I get up and what I do when I get up
and they are gonna tell you when it's time to go to sleep and when you're not
going to be able to go to sleep and so I what happens
in a church. That's at least my age.
Is that we have patterns and one of the great patterns
of our church is a Bible studies
now Bible studies are important and we're
never going to get away from those.
The the scripture is replete with with commands
to study the scripture. And so that's fantastic.
But we're not talking about Bible studies
where one person prepares and the other
people respond to the questions that they've asked.
Okay, that's Bible study where there's one person preparing. Nobody
else has to even really come prepared.
I'm not going to have anybody raise hands. I don't get anybody
in trouble here. How many of you are CG leaders and
you think maybe you're the only one who studied
the passage that week?
Right happens every week, right? Okay. We had
I see that hand. I see that hand. But yeah, so but in
discipleship, we're gonna all be reading
the same passage during
the week. And then when we get together, we'll come
together as a community of people who realize that
it's not about attendance necessarily and it's not about
you having studied so that you can expound what you've learned
upon me. It's about us learning together and US
challenging one another to apply whatever truths
we've learned that week.
So that there's accountability in that.
But there's also Intimacy in that.
Not everybody likes intimacy. Amen.
Yeah, there's Intimacy in that.
Guy's my age. We
have not been huge fans of intimacy. But
what I want you to hear me say is that Jesus method
of disciple making this isn't on page three
doesn't work at a surface level.
It compels us to connect with people in a deeply
personal way. It's life on life up front
and in your face, it's motivated by love fueled
by the Holy Spirit and the end result is
dramatic transformation. That's what we're after Community is
where God does his best work. It's how he
created us before the fall. God said it's
not good that man be alone.
So we were created for community in his likeness the
word for God there is in the plural. That's
why when you read it in a in a good translation. It says let us
create man in our own image. So
the very trinitarian nature
of God as one who is one yet
in community.
is is that's how we were designed so
nobody flourishes when
they stand alone Nobody Breaks the power of sin
or experiences a Deeper Life With God when they stand alone.
You learn how Jesus Rescues us through genuine
discipleship relationships. I
saw tonight when
I was walking through the hallway after dinner. I
saw a couple of guys who by
virtue of their Ministry they spent a
lot of time together and I can tell by the way, they were looking at each other
and laughing with one another that these guys really care
for one another and it just just reminded
me what what I'm challenging each of us to begin to
do intentionally is when you become an
intentional leader, you are beginning to plan
for a relational environment with a potential disciple.
And so tonight we're gonna discuss in the next few minutes. How
do we have that conversation?
And we're gonna look at the writings of two different men. The writer
of our book is Craig Etheridge. And then
there's another writer named Greg Ogden and they've
both listed a step-by-step process for inviting
someone. The first one is pray.
on page two and Page 8 both
writers say your first step is pray. Ask
the Lord to place on your on your heart hungry people
to whom he's drawing you to
look for people that are faithful available and
teachable. So let's while you
guys are looking for that page. Let me just say this.
Don't expect the church to
put you in A discipleship relationship. Okay, if you
wait for me to call and say I found the perfect disciple for
you, you may never disciple anyone.
Okay, don't wait for that. Okay, that's happens every
Sunday and it's called Community groups. Right? But
what what we're doing is we're asking you to become
the intentional leader and to pray about who is God
leading me to invite to be
in A discipleship relationship and you're gonna be investing
your time your energy your your love
and care and connection with this person. So
it needs to be the right person pray who
that person is and then once you've selected that person
that God's leading you to
You approach them and ask if they would think about
maybe meeting together a couple of times and maybe with a
couple of others notice that first.
It's it's attainable. Let's just
get together for some coffee and just about everybody can do that. All
right, and but then you have the
conversation the conversation. Let me just let me
just say I believe this with everything in my
heart.
that if you agree to do this
You have alerted an adversary that hates
this decision.
And so if you're not careful about where you go
to have this conversation, then you're going to have it in the wrong spot
and it's not going to go. Well, you've prayed about it you believe that God
has led you to select this person. And then you you hit
them up in between the nine
and 10:30 services and there's
people coming this way and they got to pick their kids up at the at the
hillside kids and and they just
had a fight with their wife because their wife didn't
get certain things done. But threaten they thought they would and and so
they're gonna like no no. No, there's just no
time for that. So what you're gonna do is pick the right place
and you're gonna pick a good time. Typically the
best time is the time they suggest
You know, what's a good time for you?
Well, Tuesday's work good for me. Well, let's let's plan on getting together
Tuesday then and then you're gonna ask sincere questions and this
is
this is where this opposite begins to kind of become a
it's not a step-by-step process. It's a it's a skill.
It's an art. It's a relational feature of a real
relationship.
Say hey, you know what? I am.
I'm curious about something.
And you kind of pick their interests say I want
to do something.
Where I get closer to the Lord.
And I've been praying that God would show me somebody is that
something would be interested in you would you be interested in
being in a in a group that wants to get closer to Lord? So how
are things going in your life right now?
Yeah, are you having a having regular time with the Lord alone?
Yeah, and these are serious sincere questions. I'm how's
that thing with your mom?
You know you guys are so good to ask me about my mom.
And by the way, I forgot to turn my phone on.
Okay, because she's gonna be calling, you know, she's gonna be calling here any
minute.
so
How's that thing? And it's it's a big deal in my
life. So you want to know how is that going? Well, you're gonna know the same
thing about the person you're asking could to disciples so ask sincere
questions. And then number this is
on page six make the ask.
Tell them that you've been praying and asking God how
you could get involved in our churches disciple making
mission.
You can say I went to this thing on Wednesday nights. It
was 12 weeks long. He talked about it. He wouldn't stop talking about it.
And then I don't know what I was thinking, but I raised my hand I said I was going to be a
disciple maker.
I was gonna be an intentional leader.
And then share your own story.
My story is this I was raised in a
Christian home and and I was a pretty good boy, but it
wasn't until my youth Minister came and said I
want you to pray about something. I want you to be in a group and we're gonna meet
every week and we're gonna memorize scripture together. We're gonna talk about the Bible together.
We're gonna learn how to have quiet times what we
used to call him back in a second. He's and would you
pray about it and I was in seventh grader.
No one had ever asked me to pray about anything.
And so now for the first time my faith is kind of becoming my
own.
I'm having to say.
Am I going to meet every week?
And I did.
And it literally changed the trajectory of
my life now so that let me think somewhere in
the neighborhood of 40.
To 50 years later. I'm still talking about discipleship.
Right, so it's important to get
to the place on your ask where you're clearly
stating what you're asking them to do. Tell them
what's involved is number five. It's on page nine remind them
that the micro group will be studying and reading
and working through content daily.
with two goals in mind
and these are the two goals. Remember transformation is
the ultimate goal goal. Number one, each disciple will
be learning the biblical content and responding to the group just a
minute just a minute ago. Eddie tabling
was telling me I've got an opportunity to Mentor a guy and I'm not quite sure what to
do. I said let me show you a thing on your phone that you can do or you guys can
read the same passage of scripture and you can both comment on it in real
time and you see one another's comments it goes man. That'll
be perfect.
So you get to decide that if that's what you want to do or
not, but but you're going to
Be engaging in biblical content and then responding to
the group and number two each disciple will be working at
establishing a daily habit of engaging in
God's word.
we want
we want every believer.
to be in a individual relationship
with God through his word.
Let's think of a few passages.
Second Timothy 3:16 17 all scriptures given
by inspiration of God. It's breathed out by God
in his profitable for correction reproofing and instruction
in righteousness. So that the person the man of God
may be perfect and thoroughly furnished unto all good
works. So there's that transformation for you have to have a
relationship with God's word and it ought to happen daily. Okay.
What's another one?
Good Bible verse.
Josh 1:8
this book of the law will not departed thy mouth, but thou shall
meditate on it. They're in day and night and according.
That thou mayest observe to do whatsoever is written therein.
So that
Yes, so that your way shall be prosperous and
you shall have good success. There's that transformation period good.
I love a good KJV guy man. We're on
the same team. We're saying things that some of y'all have never heard before over here.
What are they saying? All right.
Now six is gonna be up to you is the
intentional leader. We are going to provide for you and
you can see it there in your handout. We're gonna
provide for you a covenant.
And some groups will start their very
first meeting by signing the Covenant in front
of one another and dating it. They get to keep their
own Covenant. You don't hand it into the church, you know
call the the elders when someone misses a
meeting. All right, it's them covenanting with
the group and with the Lord and with themselves
say, I'm gonna do this I'm gonna
take this seriously. They need to have a see a
clear sense of what's expected of them and number seven.
disciples need to prayerfully consider the invitation
I would recommend hard wholeheartedly to
say I don't want you to answer me right now. I want
you to think about this and pray about this.
I've been praying about it and God led me to you, but I want you to know that
this is what God's calling you to do.
All right, and we'll get together next week and we can decide
if it's something you want to do or not. Okay, ask him
to count the cost.
Which reminds me of a passage of scripture that Jesus said deny
yourself.
Pick up your cross and follow me. You count the cost
and then you give the answer that has been prayerfully discerned.
Is this what God wants?
I think we know the answer.
Okay.
And then lastly set the first regular meeting
and get started. This is on page 11.
Find a quiet place where you'll be able to grow in
this intimate transparency as a group. I
don't know where that place is. I
see groups meeting at the Panera all the time.
I'm not sure how in a minute it is since it's such
a busy place but find a place where you guys can
meet regularly and and have that meeting. I I've
been praying and I'm thinking that God wants me to
start a group out of Staff members.
And and some of our younger staff
members are their hard-working. They love the lord. They're on Mission with
the church, but I just love to have an
opportunity to pour into their lives. I don't I haven't asked
anybody yet. So don't tell them.
But I might ask them. All right. So on
your discussion sheet there
is three questions first one's
got two questions on it. So be five questions all together,
I think grab and
somebody to belong to your micro group. If you're by yourself try to
find one. That's smaller and Jump Right In
and before you leave tonight began
praying about our who is it that
God's gonna ask me to to be in my first
Micro group. All right, let's pray father. Thank
you for these folks. I thank you Lord for their willingness to
to come and to be a part
of something bigger than themselves Lord. We do want to
become a church that does more than just talks about this authorship.
We want to be disciple makers.
We want to come next year and have stories that we can tell
of lives that were changed and marriages that were saved and
and Lord we want to we want
to be able to boast on you and your power to change our
hearts and lives Lord. I pray father that.
And we would be able to discern what our old
patterns causing us not to want to be able to do this and
that Lord you would give us the wisdom know how to how to
how to not repeat those old patterns, but get involved
in what you're calling us to do is disciple makers and it's
in Jesus name. I pray amen.